welcome back to another episode of
beginner C++ last episode we went over
how to basically make a class and they
think about classes they're usually in
their own file so I think this is a
great time to jump right into how you
have more than one file in your C++
program because currently we've just had
this main dot cpp and the thing about
having multiple files is well there's
two different things about this that are
pretty important in my opinion well
maybe even three so I'm just jump right
into it and start explaining those this
will make more sense if I kind of do it
as I explain it so what I'm gonna do
here is just go to where my main dot CPP
is and visual studio code allows you to
do this with shift alt R or you can
right click up here and go to reveal and
explore and you it'll bring up your
Explorer your file browser and show you
it I guess I should go to this folder in
my terminal here and the things I want
to explain are if you make just a header
file a header file is not compiled it is
included into a file that compiles so if
I make just a header and then include
that in my main my compiling is actually
going to be the same and what happens is
everything in that header file is
essentially part of this this main and
I'll show you that as a quick example
and that might be the more simple way to
do it so let's make a new file we're
gonna use touch and we're gonna call it
calculator dot H and you see that'll
make a new file called calculator out H
it's completely empty but since it has
the dot H it is recognized as a C++
header file now if we open this up its
of all blank but what we can do is we
can take this entire class that we wrote
in our main and just paste it over here
and now we have a much more simple
looking main.cpp because there's no
longer class but we are using this
calculator and if we try to compile it
right now what's gonna happen is
well-made it's gonna complain that it
doesn't know what calculator is
calculator is not declared in this scope
if we include and we're gonna use double
quotes for this calculator dot H this
isn't this goes into another thing about
includes it's important to understand is
this is a relative path from their main
dot CPP so when I do this include it's
gonna look in the same folder for this
calculator dot H which in our case do
already hard hit sum which in our case
is fine because it is in the same folder
but if you're separating these and two
additional folders I'll do it I'll do
the Linux way with make dirt and make a
directory called calculator and then
start putting on there some people do
this with their classes then it becomes
well first you got to go in that folder
so it would look like this
now there's other cases where you might
have to go back a directory and if you
need to go back a directory it's a dot
dot slash there are more things about
that they get more advanced but I think
that's enough for now so now we have
included our calculator header so we're
gonna open it back up and it's the exact
same code that was up above before when
we include this it essentially puts all
of this code right here where this
include is so it's just like we have all
this stuff except now we have it in one
line that just points to the file that
has it and we still compile our main OCP
the same and it compiles just as if it
had all that code written where this
include is so if we compile it it'll
work fine just like it did before and we
could run it and it'll do its thing what
people usually do is they have an
associated CPP that goes with the header
so there should be a
calculator dot cpp because if you just
have headers this introduces a problem
where if you use this same header and
multiple different CPP's then your
father is gonna complain because it's
gonna have the same code in multiple
places so you really only want to have
it in one place and that is the
calculator dot CVP so we're gonna change
directory into that calculator folder
that we made and if you have folders
that's great if you do it all in just a
flat structure that all is also fine and
that is often how people start out
because it's just a little more simple
without having to navigate into folders
and through folders but it's actually
pretty easy to do the thing navigating
into folders if you if you're good with
the change directory it's the same
syntax and your include so we've we've
gone into that calculator folder let's
go ahead and make another file
calculator dot CP in that should put it
in there
of course blank right now now the tricky
thing with this is and I'll just open it
and show you I'm gonna do these side by
side does this allow there it is okay so
now our calculator dot H it has it
currently has all the definitions of
everything and what we actually want to
do is only have the forward declarations
of these functions in the header and we
want to have the definitions over here
so this calculator default constructor
we actually want to end it right there
but first let's go ahead and prepare
this file before I start doing nominal
all that you do need to include your
header that of course includes all this
code including the definitions what you
normally do is you have only
declarations in your class and all the
definitions over here so we earn this
cap into just a def into a declaration
and we'll have the definition over here
now the thing about this is you do have
to scope it into the class and you do
that by taking the class
name and use the scope operator of two
colons now this will work for the
constructor so the constructor is now
properly built over here and the same
with the destructor
however our destructor does nothing so
if you if your destructor doesn't do
anything or if you have a construct that
does absolutely nothing you can just
fully delete it and get still there but
it just doesn't do anything special
because every class has to have one now
this run function we're gonna put over
here too so we're gonna go all the way
down to the bottom of it and then we can
actually delete all this and just in
that so there's a deck loop the
Declaration of the run function it's
defined over here and also we still do
have to scope it and you scope it after
the return type before the function name
just like so so now that is also defined
this first and second number we don't do
anything with that
just get in Treece it's private we want
that too now you don't have to know any
sort of privacy that's all done over
here where it's declared so we don't
need to worry about doing anything
special because it's public or private
when we're defining it you just need to
make sure we scope it if you don't scope
but you're gonna get it an error that
complains and your compiler and this
enum choice let's see it declares what
the enum is and then it instantiates a
version of it that's fine and this now
could work but it's not going to yet and
that's because we got to do something a
little different when we compile it
which I will show you so when you now
include Kevin the calculator dot H it's
only gonna get this header information
and it's not really gonna know what to
do with it because it doesn't sign it
doesn't we're not telling the compiler
to look at this file
we're only telling it to look at just
the header and the header is not smart
enough to necessarily find the associate
it's VP we'd have to somehow tell it
about this too and then it's gonna
compile that so let's just try to
compile the main and see what kind of
error we get Oh
I got to go back a directory right Oh
onion and you gotta do it's clear this
I'm you got a change directory go back a
directory if I do print working
directory I'll show where we're at do
the LS to show our current files we've
had this folder our main executable okay
so we want to compile our mean and it's
going to complain about some undefined
references so it's getting these
declarations but it's telling us it
doesn't have the definition form and the
definition form is over here so what you
have to do instead is you have to
compile with both of these like so and
then calculator is in its own folder so
we do have to do this calculator and if
you tab it will autocomplete so now this
will compile both of these we need to
include iostream here it's complaining
about she doesn't know what C out is it
doesn't know and L is and those are in
Iowa stream so it's not gonna know about
your headers from the main so that's why
it's complaining about that so I'm gonna
clear my terminal here and run that same
compilation again so let's run our ad XE
and see if it works and it does what
it's doing here is it's taken both of
these and turning these into a single
executable of this a dot exe you will
also sometimes see that you compile each
object individually and then you link
them both together so that's a thing as
well and it looks like we're not diving
into that here but usually when you have
multiple files that ends up being what's
happening is you compile each object and
then at the end you link them all
together to make your executable but if
you're just doing a straight line of all
your CPP's that seems to work fine and
turn it into one executable so when we
get to a place where we have to build
each cpp on its own and
them together I will show you that as
well but generally the objects end with
a dot oh and then you just do a final
compilation of like them all together
that would look something like this and
that puts the objects together to make
an executable so there we go you just
have to tell it about all the files when
you compile so I think that's a bit
advanced enough for the compiling stuff
I hope that makes sense and we now do
have multiple files and if you if you
want to separate out and build more
classes to work within your main you can
do that and it's essentially your rinse
and repeat the same same thing so you
might be saying at this point all right
well we still have this annoying
function that's in our main can we pull
that out as well yes let's do this let's
do that as a final thing let's get out
of that see where we're at
let's make a make a helpers folder and
then we'll go into that helpers folder
and we'll just make some make a helpers
file so we're going to touch helpers H
and helpers CVP will just open those up
that's Visual Studio code there they are
I'll put this one over here and I close
the calculator one for now because we're
all done there and what we want to do is
essentially the same thing we put our
Declaration of it here and we've put our
definition and the C fee that way it
builds over here and we can include it
in multiple files if you only do in the
header you'll notice that you can only
include it and one file or it'll
complain that it has multiple
definitions I did make a video about
that previously multiple definition of
compiler error that is very common and
this will almost take care of it we do
need of course include
come first seek a fee or help us out eh
sorry and what happens here is well I
didn't capitalize this one because it's
not a class so a lot of you know it
doesn't necessarily matter but its
standard practice to capitalize your
files if they call the class and to not
do so if they don't hold a class just
this just sold the function and we could
keep adding more functions to it we had
more little helper functions we wanted
four main that weren't necessarily part
of class and of course we're gonna need
io a string here so you see N and C out
and rather than have this whole thing
here we just include helpers up we
didn't make helpers folder name
capitalized so now it knows what this
function is it knows what calculator is
and it's simplified down a lot oh I
should change this we've done that at
the beginning and now I can still
compile just the same but now we also
need to include this helpers compilation
so it compiles this file helpers helpers
ok I gotta make this wider so I can see
what I'm doing all right
so there we go that should work this
will turn them all directly into one
executable and it looks like it's
complaining about something here oh I
have to go back a directory of course I
am in my helpers folder so let's change
directory go back a little bit I'm gonna
clear so it goes back to the top and
I'll run the same command now from the
correct directory and it looks like I
had to no errors so we run it and we're
back in let's do is subtract 5 minus 4
we get 1 do another nope
so it's properly going to all those I
hope you enjoyed this episode of how to
work with multiple files and also how to
which also turned into a little
additional information about compiling
with multiple files in the most
straightforward form where they turn or
it turns multiple CPP's into one
executable and
how to scope properly to your files
thanks for checking this out I'll see
you in the next episode
keep on coding